[Applause]  [Music]  which is  foreign  [Music]  over here  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  the end of the war  it was you see all the strong Army we  have step-by-step coming and over to our  country to all the temporary occupied  territories  and of course  it's a bit but it's a long way difficult  way because  this this war two of the best heroes of  our country  and so but for us it's very  understandable  we don't believe Russia yes and they are  drinking with all the world that's why  we are going forward we are ready for  peace but our peace for our country is  all our country all our territory  we respect the law and respect Sovereign  to all the countries but now we are  speaking about our government that's why  we are fighting against Russian language